citizens of the recheck Nation we just watched
One Piece episode five now we're about to
watch One Piece episode six Aaron how you
feeling about it buddy I'm feeling great Greg
I'm loving it I can't wait touch this leave
a like on this video people also subscribe
click that notification Bell to get notified
when our reaction for episode seven is up
here in the channel thank you to all who have
been watching with us it's been such a great
experience thank you to prepper for helping
us edit down these highlights and also massive
thank you to all who have joined our patreon
page becoming super sexy rejects over there
you can catch the full length Reaction watch
along with three sync up with your own copy
of one piece and we also cover several shows
over there exclusively with reaction highlights
and watch alongs included thank you again
to all have joined let's watch this episode
[Music] freakishly big deal with anything
sir hey can you hear me where's the first
aid kit do we even sort of a first aid kit
that scar looks more pronounced than usual
yeah I think it's been getting more pronounced
as the episodes going on everywhere
you need a doctor that is the regret the guilt
of encouragement someone needs to go back
to variety I'm really not hungry right now
Nami not for food maybe one of the customers
is a ship's doctor I don't know if you've
noticed this but every time like someone has
colored eyes I really really notice how dilated
their eyes are their pupils are huge so unless
you want to do brunch prep all by yourself
way too runny God I'm so hungry right now
right same [Laughter] 12. the nearest doctor
is on economy Island wait I'm waiting for
your going help tour boy's friend brunch is
not gonna prep itself you always told me to
defeat anyone who's hungry I don't see how
this is any different yes that's a good heart
love you Sanji bring me my kitchen knives
and a bottle of our best whiskey and a fresh
yellow towel and a cooler bigger the better
a Yellow Tail just do it already Okay I thought
he said fresh yellow towel chef's hat man
Chef Sanji and the eye is a knife beautiful
man
this is just making fish oh he's making like
a patch or like a Band-Aid what the hell stitching
them together stitch them together [Music]
it's like absorb Simon's trick fish skin now
stunts the wounds Nails the Flesh on the first
one I'm gonna be doing that from now on mayhawk
nice of you to announce yourself I thought
this was a conversation we might have privately
how does he travel where's Luffy I decided
to let him go I specifically told you to bring
him to me well I don't take orders one of
the seven Warlords you serve I would still
do precisely what I want
is he a bad guy or is he just like more morally
ambiguous maybe your grandson will be the
one to follow the one piece after all he knows
grandson and just for everyone to be hungry
man plenty we didn't use never waste food
oh
I want sushi right same Jesus I'm really [__]
hungry same not a joke right I'm really hungry
it's a problem
oh I really gotta get the what aichi monkey
ready for him hey sword can you cook sora's
favorite food what about rice will soaked
beer I can make anything just tell me what
you want dude this guy is so naturally Charming
being a captain is the toughest job in the
world so if once told me that making decisions
is what separates a captain from the rest
of his crew amen and he was one of the best
pirate captains that ever sold the Seas Seth
was a pirate captain of the dreaded cook Pirates
is to call him red leg zeph because his boots
were always stained with the blood of his
enemies how you two meet he was captured backstory
nine years ago I will want to get to the old
blueberry it's a tall tale told by Cooks to
pass the time now get to those tables
it's good I really believe the fear
he had both feet damn the blood of his enemies
nice try a little eggplant they actually want
to die quickly slow who cares I'd rather die
than have you seated my food that's not bad
better than anything you can make your own
[__] bag you've got a short time on you
boy this is like Star-Lord and yondu I picked
you up as a kid these boys wanted to eat you
so you tell me what does
I know I've been here
what happened storm sung both our ships for
the crew They're All Dead oh wow to you guys
huh start a new father son what do we do we
white oh wow did he lose his leg already now
no no this is all the food we got sorry slow
you should be glad that I'm giving you anything
at all you could have just killed him yeah
don't you bother me unless you see a ship
you got it
I'm gonna get down from there how's the ship
gonna get you what's the logistics of that
are they not talking to each other at all
I guess not
just wait till he's starving seemed like he's
about to try to cook something which I guess
not day 25 wow on that freaking Island huh
no no cover or I guess kind of cover that's
wild [Music]
oh that must be the emphasis on why they feed
everyone [Music] um
the other one's big on charging but I think
that's why Sanji is huge on it but now they
yeah they both have hearts
five days after that why aren't they bonding
this is I'd rather die than talk to you kid
moldy bread we love moldy bread good for the
soul and the spirit it's really capturing
that Stark desolation quite well yeah oh I
feel you Sanji I feel the same way how long
you think you would last on there a day a
day I'm stressed
50 days that's a strong kid right there real
trial damn
what 70 days dude that's wild three months
and ten days of little food howdy how how
do you survive
I'll kill myself it took you 70 days to get
to that point
foreign they start eating his own leg
oh he hasn't touched his food I told you to
stay cool you still have some food
oh it's just treasure oh he gave him all the
food oh wow how are you still alive he did
eat his own life [Music] what happened I ate
it boy a man's gotta do what a man's Gotta
Do yeah did he do that without screaming tough
pirate you ate it you didn't save me any he
gave me all the food why you don't even know
me why would you do that for stranger damn
harsh because we are napping on I have been
searching for the old blue my whole life but
now my time has come to an end wow you share
the same dream as me carry it on believe me
the old blue is real and if I can't find him
what in mind that you can so I'm gonna need
you to live on you have any idea what that's
like having someone lose a limb to save your
life actually I kind of too we were out there
for 85 days I'd eat both arms and legs to
say sora's life it sounds like I don't know
about all that in a certain country in the
northern Seas they're doing the Marvel hero
healing thing I said they would do sometimes
when you are in charge you have to make the
tough decisions why does everybody keep saying
that because you could have saved Zorro I'd
do anything to save him except stand in the
way of his dream but isn't there something
that you want not everyone gets to follow
their dreams it's a dream Nami will help this
whole episode's about leadership you know
Luffy is my grandson it's my ears trying to
build him into a proper Marine he is Colby's
Kobe I was trying to make him his son I spent
time with Luffy Luffy is different he thinks
for himself no matter what anyone else says
because Luffy knows exactly what he is pirate
how many assassins you sent after him he'll
never change he'd rather die first and what
do you suggest that I let him be a damn full
pirate that'd be the worst thing sir accept
things of people's choices come on come on
you can get there maybe you're right most
of the Marines on Deck I'll address them afternoon
watch
is that the shark guy from a couple episodes
ago yeah I think so
wow what an entrance I'm afraid there are
no more tables
sit down get comfortable it's up to you
let's all enjoy our last meal last meal am
I on this place well I'm our long and I own
the East blue no one owns a sea well that's
about to change once you give me what I want
what you want Luffy looking for a pirate pirate
and straw hack goes by the name of Luffy everybody
wants
that's not familiar look what his mustache
moves when he talks people already have a
meal but if you don't bring me the straw hat
boy before I finish maybe I might just start
adding some of these nice folks to the menu
everyone wants didn't Steph say we're supposed
to talk to him tell him stories what would
I say speak from the gut hey Zorro [Music]
Luffy the harlong Pirates rapper audio we
have to leave now because they're looking
for you and the map you don't need to be there
all right I'm coming with you all right kick
some ass this isn't your fight why would you
do that you fed us bring your fight this is
totally this fight they're hunting again
you stay with the ship and protect the map
be safe with you
thank God that's a complicated meal most fishermen
will be happy to sit at the same table as
a human fishermen are superior to humans in
every single way faster
that dude is menacing I'm Monkey D Luffy I
hear you're looking for me the man I'm looking
for can you find me anyway oh friend help
me track you down
did you miss me
you don't even know how to find me I told
you I've got eyes and ears everywhere
he never wait no not back in the bag it's
so dark and wet and Sandy and if you bow down
to me I don't bow down to any man or fish
and you're no King I will be when I get my
grandmother oh he's a warlord you're gonna
have to fight me for it to let the fighting
begin
[Music] he didn't have a leg for a second
oh [__] yes
[Music]
he was warned about it yep
I think Zorro's going to come in at the last
second and kind of Save the Day
I love the makeup on him looks really cool
I told you in the bar I didn't have any friends
the truth is I couldn't let myself have them
why because I always end up hurting the people
closest to me
oh You're In Cahoots with fish man is that
what the implication is well fish man's there
and she we don't know who she was talking
to of course she's gonna give him a map to
save Lucy
guys that was cool
to play on the music
come on man [Music]
come on Luffy I really do appreciate the stunt
work in this show it's really great
hey nice yeah
how about a drink sea water oh he knows all
his weaknesses [Music]
I thought it was being submerged just literally
just seawater touching him I have the map
for you just like I said I would ah you're
right Aaron what are you doing I tried to
tell you Luffy I was never on your crew I
only joined up with you so I could steal them
out
she has been for years she's a pirate you
said you hated Pirates why waste your time
killing a devil fruit eater Let the Sea do
it for you
do not know how to swim no he can't be in
water at all
let's see the body shot body shot
she betrayed you guys man so much of the question
all the disillusionment that he has to deal
with there's body shows for us I'm talking
about baby yeah gotta get that shirtless shot
oh forgot about this she's getting intense
so what a mission has changed no more half
measures the straw hats and their Captain
Will Never Surrender so the clubs are coming
off double down we will capture them and they
will be brought to Justice
I
don't need you to do that we've got a full
house tomorrow two dinner seatings I don't
want to hear this what is your problem you're
the one with a problem so get out of my restaurant
now I've already told you I'm not gonna be
a waiter you're not going to be anything no
if you stay here he wants him to go on the
adventure moaning about your blue if it means
that much to you go go find it it's a dream
it
[__] maybe I take him up on that offer
you want my permission you got it [__]
fine fine
[Laughter] the way the relationship is written
so tough it's such tough love be like I care
about you and we had a pretty great dinner
only I kind of messed it up and now I lost
Nami I lost the Grant Line map and maybe I
will lose you too this is really important
to have for the character I didn't know what
to say before but I know what to say now and
it's so simple I need you Zorro say something
to Hero You're Gonna Keep talking or let me
get some sleep turtle
you acted like a captain but her crew is falling
apart I roro Noah sorrow about a Stand By
Your Side oh [__] until the end yeah until
we find the one piece or die try yes let's
go so bring on the Marines or Pirates or sea
beasts or my captain movie yeah I'm your first
mate yeah [Music]
I wasn't worried for a second
hahaha
what do we do now plot a course for the ground
line nope get Nami getting on my back first
we're going after Nami and we need to cook
and we need a cook how did you guys need a
cook yeah yes we do
let's go welcome aboard what are we bring
in the waiter
you missed everything [Laughter] oh they ain't
gonna have their goodbye
it's his son he didn't have a father boy but
I was always your daddy
[Music] hey Sanji you keep your feet dry goodbye
zeph
you know all these years living under your
shitty roof cooking at your shitty restaurant
I owe you my life oh
thank you for putting up with my [__]
all these years old man [Music] I hope he
sees that again in episode 823.
we're gonna find her and know someone who
does did you still buggy that's what I'm thinking
yeah
what was that face
oh what a show so good girl with the sawfish
tattoo ooh okay we'll learn about her next
episode cool
is that not me I'm gonna assume it was yeah
um well Aaron please I'm on our six of filming
today you should go first okay well this episode
was Splendid it was awesome I think the fact
that you kind of spoke to something a little
bit earlier with them kind of touching on
leadership and what that means whether it
be from zeph or what it means for Luffy to
take out the mantle of leadership or you know
what it means for um Luffy's grandfather to
take up or to to uh have that role and then
um Kobe kind of falling into that that Junior
role I think it was something that was uh
prevalent throughout the whole thing and you
know we got to see Luffy really grow in this
episode really kind of step a little bit out
of that naivety but still hold that sense
of of of drive and that positivity and that
belief in people even though Nami betrayed
them he still wants to do the right thing
he still sees the good in her and he sees
beyond the fact that she's a traitor and he
sees her heart which I really resonated with
uh yes also everything with with Sanji and
and zeph seeing their relationship a dynamic
grow over the course of nine years I thought
that was very powerful and and the show continues
to do this thing where it endears us to characters
so quickly within like has Cuts all the fat
and doesn't waste a single moment and yeah
by the end of it when sanji's coming with
the straw hat crew you you feel that that
kinship you feel that relationship between
the two and it's bittersweet and it's really
crazy because granted we sell a little bit
of their relationship in the last one but
we really got to see it in this one and yeah
I think it just continues to do what it does
best which is and dearest of characters show
us heart show us what Drive means show us
what family means and yeah it's by the time
we get to this episode it's really rewarding
uh not having Zorro in it because it only
makes everything that's happened around it
more meaningful and the fact that he chooses
definitively to be with Luffy to be with the
straw hat crew to be his first man um yeah
everything we've been through up to this point
really makes that uh satisfying and I think
the only thing I would say is I feel like
um not not it's not a negative per se but
it's kind of making me question things the
fact that what is usab's role here really
um because Grant he has his two episodes in
there really good and you really have to see
his heart like what he was about and his backstory
and everything but I don't know if he contributed
a whole lot and he's been in this episode
or the last episode um I guess that's to be
seen as far as what his ultimate contribution
to this group is uh he granted he provides
laughs but as far as like being a useful part
of the team I'm curious to see what um what
role he has also when I assume they're gonna
get Nami back what does their Dynamic all
look like as a team with Sanji being the chef
with Zorro being The Swordsman usab is the
wannabe leader and and um slingshot guy what
the [__] what's that role called I don't
remember um and and Luffy of course and yeah
what what does that definitive family look
like once they're all on the same page once
they're all chosen of one another uh yeah
the fighting was great in this episode the
choreography the music was great the the fish
guys trap beats were dope yeah I I really
enjoy this episode I wouldn't say I loved
it quite as much as the last one but I think
there was still a lot of good here there's
a lot of ground work being Set uh going into
these next two episodes so yeah I it shows
continues to be great and I continue to love
it Greg what did you think this might be the
first episode I didn't like oh
that was great yeah I thought it was great
that was really important Journey for Luffy
especially I think it's really the same way
how I thought it was important for Zoro to
lose I thought it was really important for
Luffy to lose we need a Luffy to lose and
so much has been uh pushed pushing Luffy up
against the wall and having him question his
belief system and his dreams and how true
to the path of your dream how long can you
stay the course of being on your dreams yeah
in spite of everything that is to throw in
your way that's make you question your whole
belief system and I love what I love what
they did with Luffy here was it's him fighting
to maintain his optimism in spite of all that
and all the hardships thrown his way he still
tries to keep that chipper tone you know like
it it seems there's something about the performance
of Luffy that it's not disingenuous it there
there's something performative but feels intentional
about the delivery like this is the optimistic
act that he has to put on because like we've
seen the times where Luffy gets very sincere
we've seen the times where Luffy gets very
serious and Stern you know but then he's got
that very specific Cadence you know that that
that Joy so we're not seeing the actors putting
on the character Luffy's putting that on yeah
the actor as the character yeah like the character
is putting on that certain type of cadence
um it's like he's had to adopt that because
he's not he wasn't that way when he was like
a little child or whatever you know it's like
it seems like that's that was the performative
part of him that he had to put on you know
and I'm saying the character feels three-dimensional
because of it yeah you know and I thought
like here we were appearing behind that performative
side of him and I thought that was really
important for this character to really lose
because we've seen him be pushed up against
the wall have villains um pose philosophical
differences and he still comes out the winner
and I think it's super important for his care
Our Heroes to experience loss so that way
we know they're not invulnerable I think it's
very key to rooting for our characters and
how it dovetailed into Zorro at the time when
Luffy needed someone to believe in him the
most that's when Zorro came to his you know
um what is the word I'm looking for I don't
know just that that that unfleeting loyalty
to be his first mate to sort of be like you
are my captain to come around to that it affirmed
that he's in the right role that he's doing
the right yeah staunch loyalty uh is the word
I'm looking for they needed that and I thought
that was a great show the uplifting side of
of all them uh there's a really integral part
and to get the reveal on NAMI I thought was
was good it was good I do and instead of a
bummer but it feels like she'll come back
around yeah she's gonna come back around yeah
how do you feel about usop in this episode
I'm with you uh um like he gave them the ship
and I thought he was really great in the couple
episodes he was in uh he's not particularly
funny and and he was a little bit it wasn't
like annoying or anything but it was like
you're just kind of there yeah I I don't really
know what he can contributes I think he's
supposed to be there to just ask someone oh
wait to see a little bit I got two great episodes
where he was a focus and now it's like two
yeah it's kind of here and I wanted to be
imported uh I want him to feel very integral
and and um I liked the r long character
I got a question hmm I know we make our little
satirical black guy jokes um but I do have
a sincere question about it because I kind
of noticed it where it's like it seemed like
they were drawing an allegory there's a guy
who plays our long I get the impression he's
a black guy yeah the yeah and they were making
like racial allegories um with between like
the the kind of human society and how fish
people are treated you know what I mean yeah
and I feel like they would cast that's like
I kind of feel like that is a it's not really
a Christian it's really just a pondering thought
that I'm having um that they would cast that
character like get a black eye to be that
guy and because my question is like how do
you feel about that like because it seems
like that would be like the yeah you got usop
who's not really feeling like the most integral
guy and then you got the black guy being like
the main villain guy one of the main villain
guys for that kind of role and to me I'm like
I don't really have strong feelings about
it but it's just kind of another thing I'm
noticing was the residential black man here
at the only one no I thought that was an interesting
observation and you're like yeah no it was
even though he was under a ton of makeup it
was very apparent that that was a black man
playing that character and um yeah no I definitely
see the parallels between like you know these
these fish people who are representative of
of black people um being these these Pirates
are like The Outsiders of society and like
it was like something like um almost kind
of like Malcolm X in a way like I don't know
if he's Grand granted trying to like unite
all fish people but I know he gave the the
guy who was the the host like the side eye
for for working for like the man you know
uh so yeah I think that's a very interesting
observation um yeah I wasn't I wasn't something
I was actively thinking about as we were watching
it but he's talking about it now like yeah
I definitely see those those Parallels for
sure um that's why I brought you on for one
piece I heard about that there's one Blackfish
guys I just can't I just can't comment on
it for the black person and black people love
animes yeah no yeah you all do all of you
people
God damn uh but no I think that's interesting
I wonder if they're gonna take
this is why I'm here uh no wonder they're
gonna take that further or what they're gonna
do with that if they're gonna explore that
more in the the future of the show whether
it be the last two episodes of the Season
or be the God the entirety of the rest of
the series who knows yeah you know maybe he'll
uh maybe he'll start a fish Revolution you
know maybe he'll of a fish stream I think
this show is doing actually a great job I
think this Show's doing a great job on um
all it's I like I love the characters I love
Sanji I love the story of asanji here and
it it feels like one of those it feels like
one of those things where they take uh like
going through the flashbacks and such a unique
story of how they came to be and it was so
visual and mood and Atmospheric heavy and
then if so emotional at that goodbye I think
I think I think like those the way those characters
are drawn are amazing yeah and I think the
show does a great job with um diversifying
its cast especially and I guess I I am there
going it would be cool if they did get like
a truly great character who was a black person
in here you know what I mean I would like
but you know yeah okay just waiting for him
to see yeah yeah because we got like this
whole this whole main cast it seems like there's
such a rich diversity and I'm not really one
who like like I love diversity but I don't
really like fight for diversity you know I'm
not like one who's who's like a one more diversity
although he would but I don't really I guess
I don't really like exclaim about that or
Proclaim for he's not Captain diversity I'm
not um but when it's there and it's good I
like it you know and I guess like with seeing
just how great they are with the diversity
so far it was I think that's what Drew my
attention to it was like okay it seems like
we and unless we're wrong because I got the
black guy being the villain under the makeup
player that kind of character now you got
usapu they don't really know what to do with
in the last couple of episodes right so I
think that's what was drawing I was trying
to question I was questioning like why am
I thinking about it um so I would want to
see that sort of be enhanced we'll see still
got two episodes left yeah and then you know
500 more episodes
I'm still curious to know how they got saved
off of that weird Island they were on because
I'm like that seems like a weird predicament
it ran out of budget they ran out of budget
like all right they will go today and 85 they
saved us that's all you need to know that's
important yeah but I like I also love the
how how and I'm sure the anime uh does this
really well it with the fighting style of
how they've managed to uh really distinguish
the different fighting styles clearly yeah
yeah like I love Sanji being mainly like a
kickboxer kind of guy yeah the fact that they
made a guy who only kicks look good and like
I can't wait until the show has like their
Avengers shot of all of them doing their individual
fighting styles together that can be so cool
we haven't really got to know nami's too well
but what I love about song I just love that
they brought that aesthetic to life of like
him walking around and constantly with his
hands in his pockets I'm like God damn yeah
you're just seeing that kind of character
so much it's so cool yeah I will say something
else that's been something I've appreciated
has been watching is the fact that you know
normally when you're watching like cartoons
or animes they usually have the same outfit
for every single episode and I like that the
show has Diversified their outfit but yet
each variation of their outfits feels very
true and authentic to each of these characters
yeah and thematically similar in spite of
the fact that they're literally different
clothes yeah yeah that's very true all right
man that was great I'm loving the show like
two episodes left two episodes left for the
last two and the channel dies [Laughter] it's
over guys there's nothing else to look forward
to and the views are low fear every week oh
God yeah we're still still we're still kicking
strong all the time no man challenge been
great um all around and thank you guys for
being here I appreciate you but before we
head out first leave a like leave a comment
make it all about those the black people thing
we talked about and then uh for those that
stayed for the racial commentary we appreciate
you subscribe ring that Bell as Tara likes
to say and hey let's um end this with a patron
of the day shout out we're gonna round through
this with Rocket Baby pandemic Jones home
time for pandemic Jones okay don't botch this
I'm a freestyle is that we're doing here I'm
just doing it just do some rhymes shouting
out pandemic Jones pandemic Jones over here
as we shout them out on the real Rejects yeah
you appreciate this channel we love you this
isn't a rhyme this is just coming from the
heart that's just how I start this is what
I do this is my art pandemic Jones you're
the man and I know you understand what we
do here at the real rejects is for you for
your views for your heart and we love you
too just like you love us me and him watching
One Piece
that's what we do that's it that's all that's
all I got it wasn't much but it it's what
it happened it wasn't much indeed it was you
had something better come on rhymes foreign
[Music]